MEDscience is a high school biology
curriculum that's essentially anatomy
and physiology of seven organ systems. A
high school teacher teaches the
curriculum in school every day just like
every other course. Having a small school
kind of makes the school community a
little bit closer. You feel like you can
go and you can talk to your teachers
and they'll understand, like, what's going on or how
to help you because they really get to
know the students on an individual level.
One day every week, the class comes to
the Medical School and using what they
learn during the week, take care of a
patient and the science comes to life.
Real-world places need to step in and
say look, let's help to bridge the gap
between high school and the real world,
these partnerships are huge. So today we
had to diagnose Stan with a digestive
disorder and we ended up diagnosing him with
gall stones due to his chief complaint
which was an upper right quadrant issue
which is where the gall bladder is
located. We did it pretty quickly so it was good.
A lot of the kids in the class are juniors or
seniors so we're in that spot where we need
to find what we want to do, so having
like, a small introduction to something
might be able to help them hook on an
interest that they never knew that they
had. I think kids spend a lot of time
wondering why they learn what they
learn. You know, kids are desperate to
know why I need to know this and then when
they're put in a situation where they
have to know it, it's a completely
different story. When they go to MEDscience for the first time and realize
like, I can't possibly diagnose someone
if I don't know these vital signs, by the
end of that day, they know them. Being able to
come to the Harvard Medical Center's, you
know, a great opportunity and it's always
important to diversify your options and
learn something new, so that's why I decided to come. We know we're at Harvard
Medical School, but there is no wrong
answer, you do not have to raise your
hand and we're going to learn together
and we're going to have fun.
I think if kids walk away from the class
feeling like a career that was once
unattainable for me is very real and
tangible, I think that's a huge win.